et je vous remercie d'avoir répondu
cette invitation j'ai souhaité vous
rendre compte des éléments que j'ai pu
recueillir auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur de la secrétaire d'État
chargée de la citoyenneté concernant le
fond mariage font lancer vous le savez
en avril 2021 par le comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance et de la radicalisation
appelée cipdr c'est pas très beau mais
je vais faire comme ça en réponse aux
événements dramatiques du 16 octobre
2020 pour lesquels les réseaux sociaux
avaient joué un rôle majeur
comme vous le savez l'appel à projet
était doté d'une enveloppe de 2,5
millions d'euros pour promouvoir les
valeurs républicaines et lutter contre
les discours séparatistes
en application des dispositions de
l'article 57 de la loi organique
relative aux lois de finance ce qu'on
appelle la LOLF entre nous
j'ai notamment demandé communication des
47 dossiers déposés en ligne ayant
répondu aux critères d'éligibilité
incluant l'ensemble des informations
requises
la composition le compte-rendu et le
relevé de conclusion du ou des comités
de sélection ayant procédé à la
sélection des projets et à l'attribution
des subventions du fond mariage une
copie des notifications d'attribution
tout élément de contrat rendu de
l'utilisation des subventions par les
structures concernées et tout résultat
de contrôle réalisé par le secrétaire
général du cipdr sur la réalité des
actions menées
je voudrais d'abord rappeler que cette
procédure est classique
et elle est régulièrement utilisée par
les présidents des commissions des
finances du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale ou par les rapporteurs
généraux des dîtes commissions la
dernière fois par exemple pour avoir
communication vous en souvenez du
rapport de l'Inspection générale des
finances sur les concessions
autoroutières c'est le dernier exemple
en date il y en a tous les mois dans ce
cas précis j'ai activé cette procédure
suite à la diffusion d'information
émanant de divers organes de presse
représentés ici suspectant d'éventuelles
détournements ou
usage inapproprié de fonds publics
ce contrôle parlementaire est donc
particulièrement justifié et sont
déclenchement n’importe vous le
comprenez aucune indication sur ces
possibles conclusions
dans les délais proposer
l'administration à très largement
souscrit à nos demandes et je leur
remercie
quelques précisions complémentaires ont
été demandées dès vendredi dernier j'y
reviendrai au fur et à mesure de la
présentation de ce que je retiens les
éléments fournis
ces éléments confirment les choses que
vous savez que 17 associations ont été
subventionnées dans le cadre du fond
Marianne pour un montant total d'environ
2 millions d'euros
71 dossiers avaient été déposés 47
déclarés éligibles
quatre associations se partagent 1,3
millions d'euros soit pratiquement les
deux tiers de subventions avec des
montants individuelles compris entre 292
000 et
355000 euros les 13 autres associations
percevant des montants beaucoup plus
limités
le comité de sélection était composé de
6 membres dont trois membres du cabinet
de la ministre délégué chargé de la
citoyenneté Marlène Schiappa son
directeur de cabinet un conseiller
spécial un conseiller
et d'autre part le secrétaire général du
comité interministériel ainsi que deux
fonctionnaires de ce comité
interministériels qui travaillent au
sein de l'unité de contre discours
républicains
le compte rendu de la réunion de ce
comité le 21 mai 2021 qui est transmis
est un simple relevé je constate des
décisions prises
les critères ayant conduit à retenir
certaines dossiers plutôt que d'autres
ne sont pas du tout explicités
une demande complémentaire donc été
faite pour obtenir un compte rendu des
interventions des membres du comité pour
au moins une note d'analyse ou une
grille de notation des projets s'ils
existent bien sûr permettant de
connaître la motivation des décisions
prises en verrax c'est un sujet
important
concernant les projets d'ampleur limités
porté par 13 associations la grande
majorité d'entre elles semble avoir
transmis les éléments de reporting
demandés par l'administration
deux associations ne l'ont pas encore
fait mais ne sont pas hors délais et
n'ont donc pas encore reçu le solde de
leur subvention de ce fait
deux associations que je ne cite pas
volontairement dès lors qu'à ce stade
leur action n'est pas contestée sont des
partenaires du comité inter ministériel
depuis plusieurs années je ne les cite
pas parce que en les citant on pourrait
les amalgamer après dans un compte-rendu
je ne le souhaite pas pas de reproche
particulier pas de sujet
ceci manifeste je voudrais le dire une
première fois le fait que sur 15
dossiers sur 17 il n'y a pas à ce stade
d'horizon particulière de mettre en
cause les procédures ou le travail
réalisé par les associations 15
associations sur 17 et 2/3 des
financements
voilà ce que ça court et donc je tiens à
le dire il faut pas mal gamer le
problème de deux associations en réalité
avec l'ensemble du fond Marianne qui je
pense avait sa justification on verra
ensuite ils sont importants peut-être
l'année prochaine de regarder la réalité
des résultats par rapport au moyen
exercer et est-ce qu'on obtient bien le
début de recherche c'est un autre sujet
qui n'est pas le sujet de l'instant
concernant les deux autres associations
que vous connaissez déjà les noms sont
sortis très largement je les reprends le
premier bénéficiaire du fond Marianne
l'US eppm
pour 355000 euros est une association
dont l'objet la réunion de société
d'éducation physique de préparation à
l'éducation militaire de gymnastique de
tiret des sports n'apparaît pas en lien
évident
c'est un peu une litote avec les
objectifs du fond il ne fait pas état
dans son dossier de candidature
d'expérience dans la lutte contre la
radicalisation
elle n'avait d'ailleurs jamais fait
l'objet d'un soutien du comité
interministériel par le passé son projet
succinct je le rappelle je cite il
entend déployer en contenu multimédia à
travers deux voire trois sites internet
et plateformes et plusieurs comptes
rendus sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis je compte sur les réseaux
sociaux excusez-moi la raison de sa
sélection n'est pas exposée de plus
l'association n'a jamais réellement
rendu compte de son action au comité
interministériel ne répondons pas aux
diverses sollicitations de celui-ci ce
qui aurait conduit le CI PDF a refusé
d'ailleurs de verser le solde de sa
subvention le comité interministériel
indique qu'un contrôle est conduit
depuis mars 2020 sur l'action menée par
cette association ce qui apparaît pour
le moins tardif
le secrétaire général du Comité interne
ministériel justifie de manière générale
ne pas avoir été en mesure de réaliser
un contrôle détaillé des pièces
justificatives de la dépense de février
2021 à septembre
2022 du fait de l'absence de contrôle
interne financier
j'ai donc demandé de manière
complémentaire à ce que soit obtenu
justification sur le caractère tardif du
contrôle et finalement sur les premiers
résultats de ce contrôle
le deuxième bénéficiaire du fond et
l'association reconstruire le commun qui
a reçu un montant de 330 000 euros sur
le fond Marianne cette association a été
créée le 29 octobre 2020 soit près de
temps avant l'appel à projet qui date
d'avril 2021 le projet soumis au comité
a pour objet de déployer un discours
républicain adapté au code je cite et
référent culturel des 18 25 ans sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur le web au travers
des vidéos ludiques de visuels même
interview portrait reportage
documentaire événement réaction à
l'actualité
comme pour toutes les autres décisions
de subventions les motifs ayant conduit
à retenir le projet ne sont pas à ce
jour exposés dans les documents transmis
le dossier fait apparaître par ailleurs
non pas un mais deux projets de budget
2021 au montant très différents verra
pourquoi et l'association aurait
bénéficié de deux subventions l'une du
fond Marianne et l'autre hors fond
Marianne pour 39000 euros pour une
raison non précisée dans les documents
mais ça parenterait à une forme de
soutien au lancement de l'association
donc une demande complémentaire en date
ce jour a été faite ce jour vendredi
donc a été faite pour obtenir des
explications à la fois sur ces deux
montants et sur le double subventionné
par ailleurs la restitution des échanges
apostériori entre le comité
interministériel et l'association
témoignent d'après la note
récapitulative transmise de nombreuses
alertes sur ces productions
faisant apparaître des éléments
problématiques en contradiction avec la
convention signée et même on pourrait
dire avec les objectifs à signer
malgré ces multiples rappellent à
l'ordre on ne fait état dans ce qui nous
est transmis d'aucune conséquence et
l'intégralité de la subvention en malgré
tout était versé
dans les demandes complémentaires
de vendredi
on a demandé au secrétaire général
si il a rédigé une note sur les
réalisations de l'association
reconstruire le commun si la proposer de
tirer des conséquences de situation et
les raisons pour lesquelles la deuxième
tranche de subventions à tout de même
été versée
une demande complémentaire enfin
toujours ce vendredi a été faite pour
obtenir communication de l'ensemble des
échanges écrits courrier courriel du
secrétaire général avec les associations
reconstruire le commun et l'usseppm
entre novembre 2020 et mars
2023 nous avons demandé ces pièces
complémentaires pour mardi prochain nous
verrons bien donc le délai nous les
obtiendrons alors ils ont terminé par là
quelques conclusions à ce stade et
comment
pouvons-nous poursuivre
les éléments fournis par
l'administration montrent qu'à ce stade
je l'ai déjà dit mais j'y reviens parce
que c'est important le fonctionnement de
15/17 projets retenus pour deux tiers
des montants à louer se déroule
semble-t-il dans des conditions
satisfaisantes en tout cas nous avons
tous les documents qui vont dans ce sens
comme relevés par la presse les deux
dossiers les plus lourds financièrement
pose question
l'administration ayant d'ailleurs
récemment saisie sans doute y a-t-il eu
un peu d'accélération suite à quelques
articles de presse
ayant récemment saisi le parquet sur le
fondement de la 40 au code de procédure
pénale pour le plus important d'entre
eux
des questions restant suspens son très
nombreux je vous en livre quelques-unes
pourquoi le comité de sélection a-t-il
choisi deux associations l'une naissante
l'autre n'ayant aucune compétence dans
le domaine pour leurs deux financements
les plus importants
quels sont les rôles respectifs du
comité interministériel et du cabinet de
la ministre dans ses choix
et dans le règlement des difficultés
apparues
le format n'est pas qu'un fond financier
il porte de par son origine
une double exigence celle de livrer le
combat républicain sur Internet
indéniable sujet qui reste là et qui
doit être traité et de le livrer dans la
transparence et la probité
c'est le rôle des parlementaires de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement de la
façon la plus fine
le Sénat en tant que institution
dira ce qu'il entend faire dans les
prochains jours sur le sujet
pour ma part je proposerai à la
commission des finances dès la semaine
prochaine de se transformer en
commission d'enquête pour mener
notamment un certain nombre d'auditions
portant sur la gestion de ce fond et en
tirer quelques préconisations pour
l'avenir
voilà ce que je souhaitais vous dire ce
matin
vous rappelez que nous sommes dans une
démarche qui est
indépendante du temps d'une certaine
façon ne sont pas dans le temps
journalistique de l'information
immédiate nous sommes dans le temps du
travail parlementaire qui se fournit par
étape et il y a maintenant sans doute un
travail plus approfondu à faire mais qui
nécessite quelques doses à ce stade
je remercie vous avez la parole
si vous avez des questions si vous
n'avez pas tant pis
j'ai une question vous avez parlé des
bonnet pour cnews vous parlez de
production d'éléments problématique en
contradiction avec la commande signée
est-ce que vous pouvez nous détailler un
peu la nature de ces contradictions
d'abord je reprends les termes exacts de
ce qui m'a été fourni par le secrétaire
général donc je ne change pas une ligne
et je veux pas en faire une traduction
qui ne serait pas exactement la sienne
mais on sait qu'il y a des contenus je
crois même que le secrétaire général
indiqué qui avait effectivement du
contenu de nature politique qui était
contestable notamment par rapport à la
période où ils ont été où ils ont été
fournis et puis même sur le fond est-ce
qu'on est réellement sur
comment dire la valorisation de la
République si on commence à dénigrer ces
représentants le s'interroger à ce stade
il y a d'autres questions
dis bonjour François van écoute
libération est-ce que vous avez eu
est-ce qu'il y a des vous avez des
blocages dans votre dans l'enquête que
vous avez menée non je l'ai dit
et je l'ai dit aussi c'est quelque chose
de traditionnel il y a notre République
fonctionne
c'est à dire que lorsque le Parlement
exerce la mission de contrôle
l'administration lui fournit les
documents que lui demande on peut
éventuellement l'administration peut
dire il me faut deux jours de plus
me donner un temps un peu court pour
rassembler l'ensemble des éléments de
demandés c'est déjà arrivé mais en tout
état de cause il n'est jamais arrivé
j'en ai pas les réponses si on considère
que les réponses sont un peu évasives ou
insuffisantes comme vous le savez nous
avons un pouvoir particulier et de
pouvoir nous rendre dans les ministères
et consulter l'ensemble des documents
que nous souhaitons consulter mais ça
relève plus si vous voulez d'une comment
dire une possibilité je dirais pas d'une
bombe nucléaire ce que je veux dire ça
s'utilise avec prudence et dans la
réalité l'administration nous
fournissons en difficulté et cela était
encore le cas ces sujets maintenant nous
aurons une phase qui est un peu plus
qualitative qui est finalement sur les
relations entre les deux nations sont
concernées le cabinet et le secrétariat
général du comité interministériel et
qui permettront de déterminer pourquoi
ces deux associations a été choisies sur
quel critères et pourquoi on en est
arrivé au point que les deux plus
grosses associations se venaient soit
finalement celle qui pose le plus
problème
Alexandre Le Chesnay un politico
à ce stade de votre enquête qu'est-ce
que comment vous voyez l'implication de
Marlène Schiappa la ministre déléguée
elle a fait un long Street sur Twitter
hier est-ce que quoi vous est-ce que
vous avez des éléments à ce niveau là et
j'avais une deuxième question c'est on
parle de contre
j'ai oublié le mot contre propagande ou
un truc comme ça sur les réseaux sociaux
comment on
justifie l'efficacité de telle démarche
c'est quand même des vidéos est-ce que
il faut qu'elle soit vue pour justifier
que c'est
efficace c'est quand même des choses qui
sont assez floues et ce qu'on sait même
si c'est si ça a une utilité de faire
des petites vidéos rigolotes pour mettre
en avant les valeurs de la République
alors il y a deux questions dans votre
propos si d'abord j'avais
voulu parler de la ministre je l'aurais
fait dans mon propos je distingue bien
les choses je parle aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une procédure qui est
extrêmement cadrée
j'ai demandé un certain nombre de
documents dans les documents que j'ai
reçu en effet aucune allusion à la
ministre en quoi que ce soit voilà donc
le sujet concerne effectivement son
cabinet qui était dans le comité de
sélection à parité avec l'administration
et donc son cabinet j'espère que nous
aurons l'occasion dans une phase
ultérieure de l'entendre et nous aurons
aussi l'occasion d'entendre madame du
Chapat sur l'ensemble des sujets mais à
ce stade il n'y a pas de sujet
particulier Mané shabbat si ce n'est
évidemment quelle est la ministre en
responsabilité générale puisque elle est
responsable de l'exécutif et donc à ce
stade évidemment elle est responsable de
ce qui se passe dans son administration
et
de manière générale j'ai été maire
pendant
20 ans lorsqu'il y avait un accident sur
la voie publique j'étais responsable
mais par coupable mais responsable sur
moi donc il y a bien une responsabilité
générale d'un ministre par rapport
comment dire à ce qui se fait dans son
ministère voilà à ce stade nous en
sommes là et nous écouterons les
interventions des uns et des autres
encore une fois sur le sujet qui est
finalement le sujet majeur la plupart
des associations sont des associations
qui travaillaient avec le comité
interministériel les deux qui ont posé
problème sont l'une une création dans le
trimestre précédent et l'autre une qui
dans le sujet n'a rien à voir avec le
sujet cité donc c'est ça qui va nous
amener à dialoguer sur comment on a pu
retenir sur quel principe pour quel
raison les choses se sont faites ainsi
je crois que j'avais une deuxième
question me semble-t-il c'était
oui est-ce que c'est de nature alors là
vous êtes sur l'aspect un peu qui va
être l'aspect que l'aspect général sur
lequel bien sûr
la commission des finances d'ailleurs se
penchera c'est à la fin des opérations
finalement est-ce que avoir dépensé une
somme qui est au niveau budgétaire il
faut se le dire reste modeste au niveau
budgétaire de millions d'euros sur ces
opérations-là est-ce qu'elle a été utile
bon mais ça c'est autre chose c'est
évidemment la validation de l'utilité de
des opérations et ça ne relève pas
d'ailleurs directement de la commission
des finances il faudra regarder si quel
sens a donné
quel résultat ont été acquis et est-ce
que c'est une bonne méthode qu'il faut
éventuellement perpétuer d'ailleurs ce
qu'il faut aller sur ce terrain là par
ces moyens là
monsieur le sénateur Sophie broyer pour
France 2
vous indiquez en pro pour introductif
que
d'entrer Dieu vous placez 15
associations sur les 17 sur le plan de
la normalité on va dire est-ce que ceci
est le fruit de vos analyses et en quête
depuis que vous avez reçu les éléments
jeudi
est-ce que vous d'entrer Dieu vous
concluez effectivement à 15 associations
alors je relis je n'ai pas dit
exactement ça j'ai dit simplement que
rien dans ce que j'ai reçu n'était de
nature à nous inquiéter voilà et j'ai
bien dit
de manière très précise que c'était
à l'instant où je parlais et en fonction
des éléments que nous avions reçu mais
je voulais dire par là je ne parle pas
d'ailleurs de qualitatif toujours pareil
je dis simplement que les associations
ont rendu les comptes rendus qui étaient
attendus par le Secrétariat général et
qu'à ce stade il n'a pas eu de remarques
particulières par le Secrétariat général
c'est pas au-delà de ça
est-ce que la nature des liens tout de
même entre le cabinet de Marlène shabbat
et les associations qui sont concernées
fait partie de votre travail et si vous
aviez dans un deuxième temps
pas les éléments vous réclamez
concernant les échanges et les minutes
du comité de sélection est-ce que ça
provoquerait une réaction de notre part
comme je l'ai dit il y a une partie
maintenant qualitative qui doit se faire
à la fois par des documents que l'on ne
peut nous remettre s'ils existent car
évidemment s'il s'agit de discussion
dans un bureau
n'ayant pas donné lieu à un compte-rendu
il n'y a pas de compte-rendu donc il y a
rien à me transmettre c'est une évidence
il peut y avoir des mails il peut y
avoir d'un certain nombre d'échanges
formalisés en tout cas il devrait y en
avoir notamment lorsqu'il y a
perception de difficultés dans ces deux
associations à ce moment-là il peut pas
ne pas y avoir de tracé écrite les
choses
assez insistante assez clair là demain
la demande est claire d'avoir l'ensemble
effectivement des sujets d'ailleurs
avant de demander quoi que ce soit il
fallait aussi savoir combien
d'associations étaient réellement
concernée donc bien vérifier que on
était plutôt sur le cadre de
grosses associations plutôt que
d'encadre général donc c'est plus ciblé
et c'est par rapport à ce dessin là que
j'ai demandé les échanges et
communications de tous les courriers et
de tous les mails et en particulier
parce qu'il y a eu de la part du
secrétariat du comité interministériel
des remarques qui ont été faites donc
dès l'instant où il y a eu des remarques
qui ont été faites bah il doit y avoir
des interrogations écrites je veux dire
et des réponses écrites voilà et donc
c'est ça que nous devons pouvoir avoir
et d'autre part si nous pouvons
poursuivre si le Sénat décide de
poursuivre
il y aurait à travers évidemment les
auditions la capacité à rentrer très
précisément sur ces sujets là qui sont
des sujets majeurs
bonjour Florian buisson par image
pourquoi ne pas avoir attendu la
réception des documents que vous
attendez pour mardi prochain je crois
pour vous exprimer de manière publique
parce que d'abord cher Monsieur il n'a
pas une journée où il y a pas 10
journalistes qui me demandent qu'est-ce
qu'il y avait dans les documents
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait dans les
documents qu'est-ce qui avait dans les
documents donc si vous voulez à un
moment donné faut pas qu'on crée non
plus l'impression que on ne souhaite pas
donc
dès cet instant-ci nous avons souhaité
communiquer j'espère que la presse m'en
veux pas de communiquer tout de même
ça serait un comble
Gérald Andrieu de Marianne ma question
porte justement sur la communication
autour de ces subventions est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous trouvez ça normal
que le nom n'est pas été les noms des
associations n'est pas été rendus public
à l'époque et que les subventions
étaient bannies du jeune budgétaire qui
est ce document qui permet justement au
parlementaire de pouvoir étudier ce qui
est fait avec l'argent public
la question
est juste la réponse n'est pas simple la
réponse n'est pas simple
est-ce qu'il y a pas un moment ou un
temps où il faut effectivement
je vous rappelle la succession des
événements donc nous sommes après
l'attentat
quelques mois après on est dans quelque
chose
de très fort un moment très fort est-ce
qu'à ce moment-là il faut citer les
associations qui vont être chargées de
contrer le discours etc je pense que la
question est ouverte j'ai pas de réponse
j'ai une réponse technique
tout ce qui est argent public et public
la question c'est est-ce que ça peut
attendre un homme pour être
éventuellement cité voyez aujourd'hui je
ne le fais pas non plus non pas parce
que ces associations ne sont pas connues
elles ont été pour la plupart
comment dire si t'es pas par vous-même
donc elles sont connues mais là je ne
les cite pas parce que je voudrais pas
qu'il y a un amalgame de difficultés et
qu'on mette tous les noms et qu'à un
moment donné le lecteur ne sache plus
voilà
mélange un peu les choses donc pour
simplifier les choses j'ai souhaité ne
pas les
recycler maintenant elles sont
aujourd'hui totalement public donc il y
a pas il y a plus de sujets je me dis
simplement que si j'avais été à la place
du comité interministériel je me serais
interrogé et je ne dis pas que je
n'aurais pas suivi la même voix j'en
sais rien voilà
je reste donc prudent et quelquefois le
droit doit commander
à la marge mais quelquefois un handic
d'écart peut être toléré voilà un moment
donné de toute façon vous avez un compte
rendu d'exécution
d'utilisation des fonds publics et là
tout est tout doit être totalement
transparent
et la question se pose je
reconnais bien volontiers
oui j'avais une question complémentaire
est-ce que pour vous les objectifs du
fond étaient clairs s'il y avait une
divergence qui a pas mal fait débats
entre lutter contre les séparatisme et
financer de l'éducation médias ou de la
lutte contre des discours complotistes
est-ce que pour vous ça vous a paru
clair dans les documents que vous avez
examiné
à ce stade et avant audition je dirais
plutôt plutôt oui mais j'en tirerais
quand même une conclusion
ou une conséquence qui permet qui serait
dans les auditions si elles se font
c'est que
s'il s'agit notamment de lutter contre
un certain nombre de disco séparatistes
et c'est précisé et puis c'était l'objet
vraiment
d'être présent sur internet avec un
discours républicain et et un discours
de refus du séparatisme
alors on peut s'interroger pourquoi le
comité de sélection ne comprenait pas
des professionnels de ce domaine
c'est-à-dire du domaine
d'internet de voilà je pense que dans la
sélection par exemple n'aurait pas été
mauvais qu'un certain nombre de
professionnels de la communication et la
communication sur Internet soit membre
de ce jury par exemple plutôt que
d'avoir un jury qui soit un peu endogène
d'une part le cabinet d'autre part
l'administration c'est un peu endogène
j'y vois sans doute
l'idée que les choses sont construites
très vite dans un délai très court
et que
cela n'a pas peut-être amené à prendre
son temps pour dire bon voilà quel est
l'objet qui nous fait autour de la table
pour décider et pour choisir voilà donc
il y a bien il y a bien un impact
effectivement si je puis dire mais de
cette nature là plutôt qu'autre chose me
semble-t-il mais je veux dire je poserai
la question si cela est possible
sur la commission d'enquête est-ce que
vous avez vous êtes optimiste sur le
fait qu'elle puisse voir le jour est-ce
que vous avez une feuille de route à
nous annoncer déjà sur les prochaines
semaines peut-être sur cette commission
d'enquête d'abord moi je suis optimiste
c'est ma nature
et puis
je considère que mon rôle en tout cas
c'est de la proposer
après je n'ai pas je mélange pas les
gens et les rôles mon rôle c'est de la
proposer et l'institution dans laquelle
j'ai parfaitement confiance dira ce
qu'elle a à dire pour les raisons
qu'elle dira voilà mais je ne préjuge
pas de la décision d'une institution que
je respecte et dont je suis membre
il a fait la même demande suite à ma
demande
alors je rappelle aussi que pourquoi
aussi au delà du fait qu'il y a eu
comment dire des organes de presse
sérieux qui est mis sur la table des
éléments tangibles
il y a au-delà de ça je vous rappelle
qu'à la semaine nationale comme au Sénat
il y a des demandes de commission
d'enquête qui ont été déjà formulés et
que donc ces éléments-là sont de nature
me semble-t-il à justifier d'une
commission d'enquête en tout cas
la volonté d'avoir ces documents dans un
premier temps c'était de permettre de
voir s'il y avait lieu
d'avancer sur ce dossier ou pas voilà
comme vous me la posez pas je vais en
poser une dernière pour vous je vous
l'avais laissé mais bon elle vient pas
bon c'était le
l'idée qu'il y avait eu aujourd'hui un
dépôt de plainte des dépôts de plainte
au parquet je l'ai cité d'ailleurs pour
l'un d'entre eux qui a été fait par le
comité interministériel et est-ce que
c'est de nature à compromettre la
possibilité de faire une commission
d'enquête donc je vous dis bonne
question
merci de me l'avoir posé
et donc la réponse est qu'évidemment dès
l'instant où la justice se saisirait et
engagerait des poursuites la commission
d'enquête ne pourrait se tenir
voilà ce qui veut dire que si nous
souhaitons le faire il faut au moins le
faire dans les relativement
merci de cette dernière question
de ce que va décider la justice au vu
des éléments que vous venez de
d'apporter la justice peut tout à fait
légitimement s'interroger également si
elle ouvre une enquête cette semaine la
commission d'enquête que vous appelez de
vos vœux n'a pas n'a plus lieu d'être et
normalement elle ne peut plus
se tenir voilà est-ce que le délai
est-ce que le délai pardon que vous avez
accordé aux différents acteurs tiens en
compte de ça on ne peut pas parce que le
délai de la justice est inconnu donc
il faut il faut simplement que en ce qui
nous concerne dans la procédure il faut
qu'on soit capable de faire des
auditions d'avoir un rapport etc dans le
un mois et demi pas plus voilà sinon on
est beaucoup plus à risque maintenant il
est vrai aussi que la justice peut tout
de suite immédiatement déclenchée
on verra bien
est-ce que vous avez eu des éléments
quand on signalement transmis au parc
national financier non non d'ailleurs la
justice n'a rien à me transmettre et je
n'ai rien à transmettre à la vie sociale
me le demande par contre
c'est bon
merci à tous